What Khan Academy
is today could best
be described as a
tool or a resource.
It's right now if you go
to the site we have videos,
we have interactive
exercises, we
have dashboards for teachers.
And so depending it could
be used as a teacher
to help their students.
It could be used by
a homeschooler who
wants to learn
something independently.
It could be used
for an adult who
wants to review things that
might be relevant to whatever
their exploring at the moment.
But one thing I'd
like to be clear
is we don't view this as the
end all of what we think one,
this could be, and
even how students
should experience learning.
We think that this is
really just version one.
And it's a very
primitive version right
now of a tool that
will eventually
empower a true interactive
vision of education.
And the other thing I
want to make very clear
is we don't see it is an
either or proposition.
We don't see it as a virtual
versus physical a amazon.com
versus Barnes Noble.
We see it as a
virtual and physical.
Or even better, how do we
use the tools and resources
of the virtual?
How do we use those to
actually empower the physical,
to make the physical the
best possible experience.
And in this vision of what the
total education experience can
be we have a couple
of core philosophies.
The first is the idea
of mastery learning.
And I'll write it in
quotes because mastery
can mean different things
to different people.
To us this is the general
idea that students
should have deep conceptual
understanding of core ideas,
of more fundamental ideas,
before they are pushed ahead
to the more derivative ideas,
or the more advanced ideas.
And so if you think of a
traditional progression
in mathematics, although
we think that this applies
beyond just mathematics,
traditional progression
in mathematics you start
off with arithmetic.
And then you go to algebra.
And then you go through
trigonometry, and geometry,
and all the rest.
But you eventually
end up in calculus.
And what we believe is happening
for too many students--
and this is why so many
students end up having trouble
with algebra and
definitely calculus--
is they are not getting mastery
of the more fundamental ideas.
We believe if
students have the time
to really build a strong
foundation in arithmetic,
including exponents
and whatever else,
then by the time algebra
comes around they
will have a better
intuition there.
They will have a better
chance of understanding it.
And if students have a
conceptual deep understanding
of algebra, then calculus is
going to make a lot more sense.
If you do it the
other way around,
if you just push
students through
so that they get through
with 80% 90% understanding,
then what they essentially
end up doing just to survive
is start doing a superficial
level of understanding.
They start kind of
pattern matching their way
through algebra or calculus.
And not only does
that harm you later on
as you keep building
on it, it also
makes it almost impossible
to use these things
in your everyday life.
In our minds.
It's much more valuable to have
a deep understanding of algebra
and being able to see the
world in an algebraic way,
than just getting
through algebra
and kind of
understanding calculus,
but being able to apply or
really fundamentally understand
neither.
The other idea--
and this kind of
gels with
mastery-based learning.
You kind of can't
have mastery-based
learning, at least in our minds,
without a kind of self paced
reality.
Because if we really want
students to master things
we really have to give
them the time and the space
to master those concepts.
If everyone else has mastered
it and they're ready to move on.
There's no reason why
we have to move them on.
We should let them
work at their own pace.
The other big thing
about self-paced learning
is that it creates
student ownership.
And this is a huge,
huge, huge thing.
Probably the most
important thing
that you can learn while
you were learning in school
isn't necessarily any one
of these subject areas,
figuring out how to solve
a system of equations
or take an integral.
The most important thing
to learn is how to learn.
How do you take
ownership of something?
How do you, to some degree, how
do you become your own guide?
How do you set your own goals?
And this can only happen
in a self-paced environment
where, with mentorship, with
people who can guide you,
you can say, look, this
is what I want to learn.
This is how I want to
go about learning it.
And this is what I'm
going to do to get there.
And my goal is mastery.
My goal isn't just to get by.
The other thing we
believe strongly in--
and we're been working
with many, many schools.
We've been working
with many schools
across all of this,
including just how we
define our tools
and our resources.
--is the idea of students
teaching students,
or we could call it
may be peer-to-peer
teaching and learning.
And there's an
obvious benefit there
of if you have other
students around,
maybe some who've gotten a
little bit further ahead who
can tutor you.
You have more access to people
who might be able to help you.
But we think it's at least
as powerful for the student
getting tutored as it is for
the student doing the tutoring.
Because it's one thing to
do a lot of problem sets
and to kind of go
through subjects
in the traditional way.
But to truly get
mastery of something,
I think most teachers
would agree with this,
you really have to teach it.
You really have to be able
to distill it, and explain
it, and help mentor
other people to it.
And on top of that you'll
build other soft skills, which
are at least as important like
ownership, as these other kind
of tangible skills,
the skills of empathy,
the skills of being able
to listen to someone,
the skills of being
able to guide someone
without making them feel
intimidated or insecure.
And then finally, the fourth
guiding principle for us
is the idea that
students-- and this
is very core to the
physical experience--
that when students are together
they should be interacting.
So it should be interactive.
And when we talk
about interactive
and we're not talking
about computer interactive.
We're talking about
physical interactive.
They should interact
with other human beings.
They should talk to them.
They should smile.
They should see them.
And it should be inquiry based,
or exploration based, inquiry,
exploration.
And this is super key to
everything we believe.
And this is why we are
actively experimenting
with summer camps
that are driven
all around this part
of the experience.
It's because we
believe that in order
for a student to
truly internalize
all of these things--
and it all goes together
with especially
the idea of mastery
--they need to struggle
with the ideas.
They need to experience
them tangibly.
And for example,
we have students
they do things that are
implicitly probability.
But they don't know.
They think they're just
doing a simulation.
They think that they're just
playing some type of the game.
But by doing those simulations
and those games, later
on when they are exposed
to kind of the more
formal academic ideas around
probability or expected value,
they now have a tangible
understanding for them.
They now have an intuitive
And they also see the value in
the more formal representation
of it.
So hopefully this gives a big
picture of what we are about.
We are a tool and
a resource today.
But the whole goal is
to keep [? iterating. ?]
And we want people to use it
in any way that they see fit.
It could be part of
a formal program.
It could be a supplement.
It could be used as
a review of somehow.
But our real goal is how
can we optimize this tool.
How can we improve this
tool so that we can really
drive these values to make
a truly holistic education
experience?